[موسيقى]
في الساحة الرئيسية في مدينة غزة ، يستعرض محمد أبو
غاموس وأصدقاؤه مهاراتهم في الرقص المتقطع ، كان
حلم محمد
هو التنافس
خارج غزة ، لكن هناك مشكلة في
السفر من غزة ، كما يقول ، يكاد
يكون من المستحيل
هذا الشريط الضيق من الأرض على
البحر الأبيض المتوسط الذي يتسع لشخصين  كان مليون
شخص تحت الحصار الإسرائيلي المصري
منذ أن سيطرت حماس على غزة
في عام 2007. من بين أمور أخرى ، كان الحصار
يهدف إلى عزل حماس
ومنع المسلحين من
تهريب الأسلحة ،
ولكن منذ ذلك الحين تمكنت حماس ومجموعات أخرى
من تصنيع وإطلاق
العشرات.  آلاف الصواريخ على إسرائيل
وحماس
بعد 14 عامًا لا تزال
مسيطر عليها بشدة
في هانيوناس.
نفس السؤال هل سافرت طوال حياتك
خارج غزة ولم
يعط الجميع نفس الإجابة
لا  لا أبدًا مثل الآخرين تقول ريدة
إنها لم تطأ قدمًا خارج غزة
أبدًا على متن طائرة
أو قطارات تطوقها إسرائيل
من الشمال وشرق
مصر إلى جنوب إسرائيل
وتسمح مصر بدخول
كمية محدودة من البضائع بشكل صارم
إلى غزة
ولكن  من الصعب التصدير
قصفت إسرائيل
مصنع الأواني البلاستيكية للفرقة في اليوم السابق
لدخول وقف إطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ ،
أصبح موظفوه البالغ عددهم 12 الآن بلا
عمل وحتى قبل أن تحاول الأعمال العدائية ،
لأنه ربما
لم يتلق محمد إذنًا
لتصدير منتجاته
عبر إسرائيل ،
فقد استوفينا جميع شروطهم.  يقول
لكننا لم نتلق أي إجابة منهم إذا كان
بإمكاننا
التصدير أو لا يسمع الناس ما إذا كانوا
يدعمون
حماس أم لا ، والكثير منهم لا
يقضون نفس
العقوبة كما يقول المحلل محمد أبو صعدة
غزة أصبح أكبر
سجن مفتوح في  وجه الأرض
إذا لم يتم رفع الحصار ، فقد يكون هذا هو
الأقرب للطيران بعض هؤلاء
الأطفال
سيكونون على الإطلاق مع cnn
gaza.